[Music]  if the holiday season time of year when  all the talk shows give gifts their  studio audiences now Oprah flew her  audience to Australia Ellen's giving  away all these gifts for a week  we're on a basic-cable tight budget you  ready for a big giveaway here it is  lebombo covers his butt in honey and  sits on some money wait he just does it  no you just do it what what are you  doing well you're a human being  I get the feeling when they came to you  for the idea with a sketch you were  sitting and honey in your dressing room  hey go Baba with you oh I  [Applause]  oh you bet yeah you show the bomba your  you're a little bit hesitant the way an  adult would be I thought you know an  adult with children would be about  sitting and honey in front of people  making a fool of themselves right okay I  think it's funny but this part of me  this is now unlike him  [Music]